Haley is with us Haley is in Texas hi
Haley how are you hi Jane oh my goodness
how are you how can I help so I my
husband and I have just started this
we're not even a month in and we used
our tax return to pay off for credit
cards and we still have I go to school
and I have two student loans ones from
the evil navient and then the other ones
from Great Lakes and my question I
actually have two but my biggest one is
should I or can I consolidate my greatly
student loan is it possible and is it
worth it
it's 29,000 seventeen dollars and 28
cents
what's the interest rate on it well
there's three of them and it is and so
there's two of them one 5% in the other
700 on it what's the interest rate on
the navient there's three of them and
it's 29 altogether
interest rate yeah no now it doesn't
have 29 interest rates I mean altogether
that I added it but what are the
individuals no it's it's not calculated
that way what are the individual
interest rates right Navia loans like
you gave me three different rates on the
Great Lakes loans right five five and
seven right okay what is it on that yeah
I'm not sure I think it's like seven
like I don't know in my head we of them
in a total 29 one of them's over 10 yeah
okay I know there are Wyatt I mean okay
well the only reason you consolidate
student loans is if you get an end up
with a lower overall interest rate and
and so it's not adding them together
like that where you get 29 that's not
the calculation you get
you got five on a certain amount and
that amounts to a certain number of
dollars and you got seven on a certain
amount and that mounts to a number of
dollars and so on and overall navien so
you've got six different loans you would
calculate and then say okay it is the
net effect of this so for instance if
you could consolidate them at 6% but
some of them were at five and some of
them were at twelve and the total across
the whole board was larger than 6% then
you would do the consolidation okay and
so it mattered I'm sorry okay so you
don't have any refinance costs if you go
to splash financial that we endorse okay
and they can help you I tried to go
there that they said that they don't do
it if you haven't graduated OH
I'll be true okay so when do you
graduate so I I went to lis in Cleveland
and I didn't get to so I'm into Texas
and said I was originally in Tennessee
are you currently on a school no well
then thank you they didn't understand
they thought they thought you were that
they thought you were still enrolled
they won't refinance them if you're
consolidate them if you're still
enrolled but if just because you didn't
graduate doesn't keep them from
refinancing that's not how it works
so holler back at him again jump on the
phone with him they'll help you they're
good folks and what you need to do is
you've got to calculate the overall rate
and compared to the current rate they're
quoting you and then that will tell you
what the best way to go is you probably
do need to consolidate these because it
will save you some on interest but
overall Haley your bigger problem is not
your interest rate your bigger problem
is to get your income up your outgo down
so you start chunking big dollars
towards these things because they're not
going to go away based on interest rate
they're gonna go away based on big Airy
principle payments that's what makes
them die gu away
Sallie Mae go away navient
go away Great Lakes but ya holler back
at splash and talk that through with
them again and then start working on
things you can do to get your income up
and get yourself on a really really
tight budget you know you can do this
you can do it it'll work for you